[Musica]
anche in mezzo a bombe minacce e bugia
il mio desiderio è sempre quello
tenere aperte delle finestre umoristiche
da quando è riapparsa la guerra in
europa nei balcani e dopo l'undici
settembre
ho disegnato molte vignette sulla guerra
e sulle sue conseguenze questo disordine
globale in cui siamo immersi
e poi quando le raccolgo per libri opera
mostre l'intreccio sempre alle vignette
sulla violenza maschile contro le donne
le due cose sono appunto strettamente
intrecciate io collaboro dagli anni 80
con i primi centri antiviolenza come il
cadmio e ho scelto questo registro
l'umorismo i droni ha anche per questo
argomento al centro della guerra dei
fumetti sulla guerra è nata una
personaggio
il suo nome è cassandra che ride e la
sua antenata e la cassandra omerica
vigente sacerdotessa nata a [ __ ]
tremila anni fa le sue profezie perlopiù
di sciagura non erano erano destinate a
non essere credute ascoltate e per
questo cassandra si sentiva impazzire
una scrittrice tedesca christa wolf ha
avuto un'intuizione su di lei ha detto
un tratto umoristico in ogni pazzia
chissà riconoscerlo e usarlo ha vinto la
mia cassandra che ride infatti ha
trovato nell'umorismo in questo
linguaggio
la possibilità di una via d'uscita
la possibilità di riproporzionare le
cose e di dare riportare a una misura
umana
fatti che sembrano enormi sembrano e
incontrollabili e quindi la possibilità
di tenere la testa a posto
per fare questo l'umorismo a tante
chiavi racconto due una è che chi fa
umorismo parte sempre da una posizione
di debolezza e apparente forse però di
debolezza come quella dei bambini che
dicono la verità o quella di cassandra
che non era creduta però nel gioco
complesso e anche istintivo
dell'umorismo questa debolezza si
trasforma in una una forza che spiazza
in un lampo e poi molto sinteticamente e
è una forza che poi crea un piacere e
poi l'umorismo è un atto relazionale ha
bisogno di compagnia di condividere
questo piacere con altre altri è un
invito al gioco e questo è per me credo
il sogno il desiderio che davvero è
diventato realtà nel poter fare un
lavoro che che è che è un invito a
giocare insieme
l'altra cifra è che bisogna stare in
compresenza e in prossimità con
l'oggetto di cui si tratta per fare un
lavoro davvero efficace e questo vale
principalmente per la satira non potrei
fare battute scherzi su stereotipi
culturali di civiltà che non conosco
bene di cui non ho una una percezione
forte che non mi toccano veramente alle
radici lo posso fare su cose che in
qualche modo risuonano dentro di me e da
qui sono molto toccata che sento sulla
pelle e succedeva così anche ai buffoni
di corte
che dovevano stare lì presso il trono
del re per vedere da lì illuminare non
un attimo
gli intrighi della cortigianeria gli
eccessi del potere regale e succede così
anche alle donne che irridono l'orco di
turno come nella cronaca di questi
ultimi tempi ma nella sua essenza
io credo che l'intento di chi fa questo
che chi fa umorismo sia molto simile a
quello del bambino nella fiaba di
andersen cioè svelare che il re è nudo
[Musica]
ciao
no
[Musica]
bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vengo da una famiglia con molte donne
che sono state le protagoniste il
pubblico originario dei miei fumetti il
teatro familiare era denso di tensioni
drammi melodrammi e questo linguaggio è
stata per me la possibilità di dire la
mia verità di dire la mia e di farlo
facendo anche ri delle mie sorelle poi a
vent'anni erano gli anni settanta ho
incontrato il femminismo che ha nutrito
e fortemente incoraggiato il mio
desiderio di usare pubblicamente questo
linguaggio letteralmente di pubblicare e
di farlo non partendo da astratte
rivendicazioni di diritti o da ideologie
ma di farlo partendo proprio da me dalla
mia emozioni esperienze e dalla
consapevolezza che si andava generando
nello scambio nello scambio con le altre
oggi quando mi metto alla scrivania io
disegno sulla carta prima di tutto sono
preda delle emozioni più discordanti
possono essere molto confusa su quello
che andrò a trattare possono essere
molto arrabbiata ci sono tanti motivi
possono essere molto ansiosa perché sono
molto molto molto ansiosa e però è a
poco a poco nel farsi di del lavoro nel
farsi dell'opera a poco a poco cercando
un equilibrio fra il testo è l'immagine
che è l'arte del fumetto
affinando uno sguardo o la metrica della
battuta addentrandomi a poco a poco alla
fine
trovo una via d'uscita è la realtà
stessa si trasforma davanti ai miei
occhi
questo può avvenire su tutto sul mondo
sui rapporti fra i sessi sulla guerra
sulla cucina sulle opere liriche su
sulla violenza come avete visto
sul femminismo su tutto dedico molto
spazio da molti anni al tema del lavoro
ho disegnato decine e decine di
diventate centinaia di annunci ironici
di lavoro e una ossessione e poi anche
lì sono nate delle personaggi di solito
io non caratterizzo tanto i personaggi
sono quasi archetipi è però a volte ad
alcuni do dei nomignoli e diventano un
po come delle padrone di casa qualcuno
che dalla conversazione a dialoghi e nel
lavoro è nata la bella addormentata fa
il turno di notte che racconta i
cambiamenti le crisi punti di crisi
provocati dalle donne e nelle donne
dall'ingresso nel mercato del lavoro non
dico mondo perché si è sempre lavorato e
l'ultima nata è la bracciante digitale
che lotta contro lo strapotere dei
latifondisti del web
naturalmente anch'io come la bracciante
digitale come la bella addormentata
anch'io nel mio lavoro sono coinvolta
nella crisi nei grandi stravolgimenti
del lavoro nei campi che sono miei
propri il giornalismo l'editoria e
l'arte è però ci sto dentro con il mio
lavoro ci sto dentro quindi elaborandolo
e essendo testimoniando con le vignette
e in qualche modo trasformandolo in
questo modo è in questo senso per me è
un azione politica una lotta di
liberazione con armi leggere molto molto
leggere che cosa accadrebbe se non ci
fosse più niente da ridere
non lo so perché cassandra che ride non
prevede la fine del mondo
[Musica]
ciao
[Applauso]